yeah buddy
it's been a while since I've done a
video so I thought I would check in from
Kona it's Monday morning race week
ultraman starts on Friday I've been here
a week they have got a beautiful resort
up a place called cooky uh but I had to
move out of there so I'm now in this
pond out here but as you can see not a
bad spot so just got back from a morning
run ran down by the pier saw a couple of
the competitors I ran into Alexander
Roberto here he's looking extremely fit
and then I might run I finally met Jonas
this race like six times or something
both looking extremely fit anyway I'm
happy to be here my family got in last
night on 10 acres where we're gonna hang
out after the race is over
so feeling good had a good run this
morning we swim a little bit later and
what else can I tell you I show you my
race bike looking sweet
Ranko OTP shrimp weds give Matt fiber
wheel set and a quark
I love these wheels they're incredibly
light so what's great about them is that
you get the Aero advantage of the d-plan
wheel but they're much lighter and
4:08 so to climb really well very agile
and as you can see my bike is slightly
modified from a regular TT bike and that
I have a road for I'm here as opposed to
an arrow TT 4 that's to give me a little
bit more control over my handling and
also to make the bike
so it's not the standard TT bike it's a
little bit customizing Churchill eyes
but if you'd agree it's looking pretty
sweet so it's really fast I've been
enjoying it it's really great you want
to know more about franco bikes check
them out franco bikes calm or Franco
bikes on Twitter great guys
they've done an amazing job supporting
me with amazing bikes and support so I
love you guys get here so what else let
me just show you a little bit of
nutrition setup Juiz bringing the
Vitamix downs I don't have that right
now
back here a whole bunch of race and
recovery nutrition pull Brendan brazier
was nice enough to send me a whole array
of the new line of Vegas pork products
they all these pretty workout
post-workout Jones electrolyte which is
pretty cool and then we seem to make it
some more nurse and it's an awesome
stuff their warrior blend farmers greens
I love this stuff all the things I need
to make my morning blends but anyway I'm
gonna try to do a little bit better on
the videos it's been so long since
anyway then you can follow me along on
this journey I hope you do
Morgan Krishna Metta bender has set up
his live GPS trackers for my website
which is going to provide like a really
cool and robust and user experience for
people that want to follow along or see
where I am they'll be unlocked by Matt
I'll have a GPS unit on my seat post
therefore so I'm live site you'll be
able to see me on the map live telemetry
and my crew be uploading pictures and
videos when they can and they'll be a
Twitter for you go to
anyway to check it out the rich goal.com
backslash live during the event I think
hashtags we're going to be using Twitter
are going to be um 2011 and Ultraman
live we want to follow the grace on
Twitter that's quite the best better
anyway we check it out checking it with
you later